salut tout le monde salue fabien nous
allons aujourd'hui suivre donc ce
fabuleux blitz entre magnus carlsen et
hikaru nakamura
voilà exactement donc là c'est parti et
c'est trop près aux coups sur conan de
carlson mais c'est en train de
transposer dans la vente de chevaux va
donc une jobin qui s'appelle le
probablement hinchey gorille non à
inverser famille royale en c3 mais
lorsque oblige de ses 5
alors là on vous prépare ses soins
cassis et leurs boîtiers pc sont les
deux fous qui sont sortis fabien est ce
que le cavalier b8 donc on va plutôt cc
cinq en premier le maître ans et 6 ouais
je pense un solide et vous faire aussi
ses 5 parce que des fois contre et c'est
ça qu'il ya des français adhéraient à
des blancs furent sacrés champions donc
à voir
ok il faut des trois bouffe je pense le
contraire de la même chose du pion
d'après du pian d'ailleurs étonnant dans
cette prise il double les pions au
centre fabien quelle est l'idée battu
contrôle bien les quatre centrales comme
ça aux quatre c4 tout ça tu as la
colonne s'est un peu pointe à tour des
fois devoir en attaque avec l'avancée du
pion bessilles large accès 6 on peut
nous attaque de minorités et puis aussi
pourquoi pas jouer aux quatre un joueur
quoi donc
nakamura attentes des changes est lui
aussi le fou donc le fou de casement
c'est censé être le mauvais fou pour
karl scène il était sur une bonne vague
de nage
c'est pour ça qu'il est venu chasser
main il vient clouer le cavalier de la
camra ouais bon après pas un clouage aux
programmes
on va voir quoi mais c'est une bonne
décision ne pas échanger sous sinon
après s'il faut prendre et cissé prend
17 royal trop haut trop symétrique donc
carlson qui garde qui garde de quoi
jouer et ils poussent eux quatre ils
menacent 5s que nakamura va le voir
fabien je pense qu'il va le voir
il admet il se regarde qui montre par là
qui est vraiment un des murs vides
seront monde
ouais c'est vrai que ceux ci occupent du
fou pour éviter la fourchette c'est très
très bien joué
du coup dam des trois est donc ce pion
bessac fabien dans les dents les gambie
dame souvent une faiblesse une fois que
le foot cases blanches et partie qu'on
peut venir un peu gêné mais exactement
ballon l'attaquant donc maintenant
montant total des cinq
ok qui et b6 peut défendre les deux
n'étaient pas forcément très content
monsieur gayant b6 qui sert pas à grand
chose mais bon ça se trouve il faut
faire d'ailleurs c'est ce coup joué par
le 40 km en b si souvent mal placé
fabien ici on voit qu'il aurait pas de
case pour avancer plus entre guillemets
c'est à dire c'est 4 à 4 sont bien
contrôlées donc il est un peu condamnés
à rester sur cette case donc la tour
seul jeu pour carlson très bientôt sur
nos colonnes au vermont entre les normes
forêt doit organiser en fait récupère
donc tu fais c'est si je pense qu'ils
n'en avaient dans lequel edf qui s'en
suit et changer un peu des pièces etc
moi tout seul nom pour le moment ça
tiens c'est toujours très solide un pur
pour les noirs hikaru qui il ya un petit
problème des spasmes et c'est pas non
plus gravissime pour le moment non ça va
donc ok avec toi et toi fois jeu mais il
est vite acquis et 17
c'est une histoire de clouage les pions
des 5 à la fin qui s'attaque au quai
d'orsay il doit fait ok ça lui aussi
associé doit pouvoir et clément comment
il compte renforcer sa position en fait
s'il a tout mis en place mais tu vas
mourir h3c pas des coups très menaçants
pas si j'ai des petits coups
d'amélioration quel suspense du body
language de carlson regarde l'air d'être
cannes bien assis sur sa chaise j'ai
lancé il est un peu comme comme un lion
qui veut sauter sur sa proie n'en ont
sans regard est vrai je me recule un
petit peu on sent qu'il est chaud en
fait ce choix je pense qu'ils étaient
faux soit pile 1.7 comprend des
symptômes qui prend des 5 pouces avec le
plonge mais notamment avait invité le
tour ses huit passes qui auraient une
tour c'est un qui sait changer cette
dictature de 1,3 à 9,7
ah oui ok ok j'espère que nos auditeurs
ont comprimé tour français a forcé à la
tour en a alors pour ça que je tour si
tu t'aventures qu'il y avait 17 et du
coup personne à tfo jitrois toi tu es
dans lequel vincent se tient toujours
mais qui contrôle de plus pour les
blancs au sens c'est un petit truc un
petit plus mais koffi président de vinci
tué par une carte elle ne sait pas si
les idées claires en fait il fait les
petits coups il avait l'air un peu mais
concrètement tu fais quoi
et si on enlevait sa dame fermée quatre
peut-être des choses comme ça mais
parfois fabien ne rien faire vos échecs
ton adversaire tu dois faire quelque
chose en face donc tu attends tapis tu
change pas grand-chose et petit à petit
avant c'est un petit peu puis ont donné
ton adversaire lui aussi doit bouger
c'est pas évident à jouer côté noir n'a
pas trop des spasmes saas nous traçons
ouais mais regarde cette dalle des huit
peu plus a lancé cette le fou j'ai trois
contrôles quand même pas mal de casse
s'est légèrement désagréable quand même
un tout ça moi qui ai fait ça il fait le
b 4e tout ça m'est arrivé de faire du
jeu a qu'à 5 trouver du contre je
reviens fonds qu'ils ont pour le moment
pour le moment hikaru qui a pas mal joué
quand même je trouve avec son son petit
tour à 8 fabien il a bien réagi à cette
à trois des quatre en trouvant du contre
jeu avec des idées de à 5 qui peuvent
arriver éventuellement après la tête par
une personne trop vite parce qu'à ce
compte des cinq coups mais c'est un peu
une guerre des tranchées comme l'instant
c'est un peu le coup de deux tours
mystérieux de nîmes zollitsch ce tour à
ok pas accès car sinon ça un trait de
bones drame le cas les verbes et 3 pour
les verts à 5 ou c5 un peu fixé le 17
ça prend forme posticheurs c'est vrai
que s'il arrive en a cinq qui pourra
même plus être chassé par b6 à cause du
pion c6 qui pourrait être en prise tout
à fait donc ça peut être une très bonne
idée qui avait troqué la cinquième en
plus à venir a pris 2 à 5 de carreaux
dont qui va rendre à 3 mètres minute y
ait un écart ou qui jouent solide la
tour eiffe ans et 8 qui en décèdent tout
le monde revient à l'ale dames c'est
quoi et sur quelle sont peut-être juste
revenir en réussissant fait alors toi
ils recommencent à faire des menaces sur
la colonne avec la dame hockeyville jump
ça commence vraiment à prendre forme
pour les blancs ici fabien genre humain
entre même sur votre argent volé le roi
avec 4 et 5 par exemple
oui et puis tu vas complètement fixé
cette tour
cette tour en à cette chaleur beaucoup
de mal à revenir en jeu là les pois a
passé beaucoup des changes le pion des
cartes et maintenant il ya les plans à
la b5 b6 turenne a vu arriver un don
qu'elle améliore pas ce qui va devoir
faire pour te faire c'est justice ou g7
qui diffuse kye-ossi stocks et attaqué
des quatre plans katic
mais pour l'instant enfin même les
blancs sont mieux maintenant c'est clair
pour moi mais bienvenu c'est petit mais
si ce conflit partout on va voir qui va
sortir gagnant ces échanges tchadiens ou
là au moins tu as un bon ça va bien ce
liquide et métal a lancé six loups et
donc le plan c 5 des petits problèmes et
un petit avantage de l'espace depuis sap
vous activez c'est un peu comme dans les
halls et là quand on fait le dessin qui
est que tous sont au mieux
souvent c'est mieux pour le camp mieux
vaut mieux développer quoi après hikaru
c'est quand même assez assez joli ce
qu'il a fait puisqu'il a réussi qu elle
part à activer ses touriste il avait
l'impression qu'il était très mal placé
que ses tours ses 8 à 7 qui était
complètement bloquée finalement en
jouant comme un équilibriste
il s'en sort quand même très très bien
mais c'est le point fort du caroux
fabien sort car ces équilibres tout à
fait car ces tours j'ai su alors
attention évitez me ranger plus tour
pour découvrir dans ces huit qui peuvent
arriver des trucs comme ça non s'il
prendrait ou quoi attraction le pion g2
fabien pourquoi pas un match qui
pourrait arriver je sais pas d'âme g5
carlson ne le voit pas et ce point à
tanger de faire attention et du coup la
dame b sat pas mal placé elle défend g2
à distance du coup tu as un projet de
maths non dame projet de l'est plus à ce
liquide de plus en plus
ouais c'est ça de mes jeunes rivales
gagnon génération c 5 oui il le prend
avec le pion et du coup il à la tour
derrière les des 5% à 14 6 bat et on
s'est peut-être fou des six maisons tu
déjà débloqué les 15 minutes et malpas
jeu départ est dû qu est-ce qu on peut
pas tenter cahiers français ça tu veux
cette finale qu'il veut je c'est
finalement avec moi la tour demande
je passe ça donnait ça
c'est ce tous les tours ok c'est ce vote
nul ça non j'imagine mais parce qu'ils
aient encore les quatre tours sur
l'échiquier on n'a pas pu échanger de
perdre deux tours et ça devrait faire
nul mais bon c'est du blitz fabien ya
plus beaucoup de temps la pendule voile
sur un personne plus bon techniquement
quand il est mieux c'est probablement le
meilleur du monde aujourd'hui et
peut-être le meilleur de tous les temps
un an ce type de position ses avantages
en finale le fait de devoir sur les plus
ancrées nord ce qui pouvait aussi non
sucré de monsieur besson
ouais c'était une mauvaise technique
alors était-il obligé de le faire ou pas
pas sûr mais là c'est vrai que le roi va
rentrer réussir à rentrer ou là et c'est
peut-être encore une finale je n'ai le
roi où tu vas faire et où 4 à la fin
ouais bah j'ai f4 il en train de
calculer et c'est ce qui va faire
hello world iv l'hameçon g53 leucate g3
wave 3 ça va arriver fabien rentrer en
sauce son sens
howard wimbledon ça devrait faire nul
ouais on voit que les joueurs se
regardent
c'était très chaud je pense qu'il a une
partie et qui émane du c'était mieux et
une bonne résistance du caroux donc
trois contre trois l'équipe hockey